bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors vous êtes
anesthésistes ans dans un hôpital des
pays bas on en parle de cette reprise
épidémique qui semble toucher à toute
l'europe est ce que dans l'établissement
dans lequel vous exercez vous sentez
cette reprise épidémiques
ont fait plus que la 100ème jantes en
est en train d'en nouveau de retarder
des soins on est obligé de s'adapter à
nouveau on à nouveau un département
corps spéciales cos vide c'est une c'est
une pandémie n'est pas démis de non
vaccinés si il n'y avait que les gens
vaccinés qui sont en échappement à cause
de limite et c'est sans le savait on
pourrait gérer on est dans les problèmes
à cause des non vaccinés pour des
raisons religieuses pour des raisons de
complotisme ou de suivre des décidé
complètement folle
donc ma des restrictions arrivent et
bien falloir que les gens se fassent
vacciner mais pas tellement choix alors
ça veut dire comme les nouvelles
admissions à l'hôpital en les nouveaux
malades qu vite que vous recevez sont
majoritairement des non vaccinés oui oui
c'est majoritairement des nouvelles
signer surtout envers des chiffres
proportions ben on réagit un peu près
regarder on a ces 30%
de vacciner mais son descendant avec des
cancers des chimie etc donc ça on le
savait le reste c'est non vaccinés
refusions dans les services on voit des
patients là aussi très âgées qui sont en
échappement vaccinaux mais le rêve s'est
majoritairement des gens non vaccinés
alors on vacciner aux pays-bas la
couverture vaccinale si je me trompe pas
c'est plus de 80% de la population de
plus de 18 ans qu'un schéma vaccinal
complet pourtant on parle d'une reprise
épidémique alors on s'interroge ya
certains qui s'interrogent sur le rôle
un de la vaccination
il faut relativiser par rapport à
l'année dernière on avait un autre
variante était moins contagieux on a
varié delta qui se promènent qui se
propage à toute vitesse donc on te
regarde les chiffres c'est partiellement
de sa carrière les chiffres simplement
brut faut penser qu'on ne peut plus
permettre d'annuler de décaler des soins
donc tous les lits qui sont occupés on
en a besoin pour autre chose les lits
sont peu extensif à on est en 2021 on a
des durées de séjour qui sont
extrêmement courte 1 de quatre jours à
peu près en hospitalisation aux pays bas
on a plus haut tandis qu'avant on a plus
de personnel comme avant on est plutôt
confronté à une réduction de lits dans
le but d'une efficacité et d'un meilleur
autres comme des patients et on a pu la
place pour tous ces gens non vaccinés
qui occupent des lits c'est sûr que
c'est beaucoup moins qu'un an mais il ya
un an on annulait tous les programmes là
on peut plus se permettre donc à vous
craignez donc une saturation des
hôpitaux ya donc un nouveau tour de vis
aux pays-bas retour du masque en eux
fermés la distanciation sociale et
l'extension du pain sanitaires
manifestement les autorités
réfléchissent à la mise en place de ce
pas ce dont les entreprises vous en tant
que médecin vous en pensez quoi
100 % pur
pour nous tous les lieux mêmes de
discuter
gens quand je trouve que les autrichiens
qui met ce système 2g 3g
et très bien il va falloir contrôler
beaucoup plus que les gens qui ne
veulent pas se faire vacciner c'est très
bien qu'ils se testent les jours - et
sur place justement niveau de la
population comment perçois tel comment
re soit elle a en ses nouvelles
restrictions sanitaires enfin le retour
de ces restrictions sanitaires
on n'a pas l'impression que ce soit mal
vécu le retour du masque bon c'était
assez rigolo parce qu'il resurgit aller
faire des courses personne mais ted
masquer ce matin tout le monde en avait
point tout le monde a attendu vraiment
le dernier moment mais tout le monde le
fait on n'a pas la sensation que ça y
est c'est un drame tout le monde
comprend et on voit bien que les rendez
vous pour les vaccinations monte en
flèche nous avons failli hier vous êtes
années s'est éteint à l'hôpital de dors
très chaud aux pays bas les pays bas qui
a annoncé le retour des
mesures sanitaires merci à vous d'avoir
été en direct avec nous